well I see that a brave base behind you
and I'm just curious I mean can I
convince you to play just a little
something maybe or yes well you know I
don't know if I have any bases nearby
but if I did I love it in life when we
can be within six feet of each other we
got to do something together I want to
sing while you play bass that's what I'm
talking about I would love that I you
know I have them I always play my bases
but I find it's like that it's become a
ritual now before my newscast I put on
some music at my little home office and
then I started jamming and it kind of
gets me in this like headspace to do the
news every night so it's fine thanks for
asking I love it I love I like I was
telling you before my bass player is so
amazing he'll go like how you ever have
my bass back there he'll go you know
from from different kind of bases and
it's just such a smooth sound and people
know this but actually they always think
it's the drummer bits to base the drums
that really hold down the rhythm and
everything of a set yeah if you could
pull out the bass track you know you
would realize how much a part of you you
know you don't often hear it consciously
but man you take it you remove it from
music and everything changes yeah and
then it's like wait where's the where's
the beat and where's everything yeah
it's it's a it's so cool sounding - it's
a sexy instrument subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe my
channel
these don't make me keep going